gary mulligan you've had some odd
reviews over the years
[Laughter]
what did somebody describe yourself no
this wasn't a review i try not to read
reviews
i try not to and then sometimes i get a
bit drunk or something and i'm like
i'll just have a look
yeah and um no this wasn't a review this
was i was filming suffragette
and we had a slow morning it was a
sunday and i got the sunday papers and i
opened
something and some someone was writing
about me
for no particular reason just because
and described me as a human balaclava
and i was sort of hurt but also really
confused
so my obviously means i'm boring but you
know does it i don't know
i think toasty and intimidating
but weren't you on stage oh yes when i
did 40
yeah my first stage play i was 19 at the
royal court and um
i was doing a kevin elliott play and it
was very serious
and um and about four of the review i've
got quite big hands and quite big feet
sort of manly you're staring at me
i don't know they are comparisons oh man
i've got
monsters okay they're all very cool
but about four of the reviews mentioned
how big my hands were see when you do
that they do look quite big
i think i was also acting a lot with
them you know doing a lot of things
and meryl you've never had a bad view
have you ever had a bad review
oh yeah no oh yeah how bad
uh well i remember once
in um a woody allen movie that they said
oh this is the best performance by a
head of hair
i have really good hands
i think we have a picture of you and it
is in fairness good hair
upstage by your own hair i used it like
a curtain
sometimes i'd have it this side
sometimes the other side and it was very
deep performance
[Music]